Спочатку ти прокидаєшся, збираєшся… Це трошки ближче.
Береш, що тобі потрібно для роботи, і виїжджаєш до Старого Салтова, де переходиш або перепливаєш водосховище.
Ось таким чином ми їздимо на роботу.
Приїжджаємо на власних автівках, потім ми залишаємо їх тут, і коли є великий мінус, мінус 10 і більше,
то замерзає вода, ми переходимо на інший бік і там їдемо на автобусі чи на автівках, які знайдемо,
або які приїхали за нами. Зазвичай на автобусі.
Я родом з Луганської області, з Луганська. Мені 26 років.
Мені 25 років. З Вовчанська, я тут виросла, я тут народилася і працюю.
У нас раніше, до війни, вікова категорія була 35-40 років.
З початку війни багато працівників поліції - хтось звільнився, хтось перейшов на бік ворога,
і залишилися працівники 25, 27, 30 років.
Ой, зараз прилетить…
Це декілька разів на добу. Від двох до семи-восьми обстрілів. Ну, це у Вовчанську.
Наша робота така, як і в інших слідчих в Україні.
Ми збираємо докази, ведемо кримінальні провадження, реєструємо їх, закриваємо їх, передаємо до суду.
Документуємо злочини проти цивільних, проти їх майна і все, що з цим пов'язано.
125-та [стаття]. Сьогодні підійти до дільничних, допитати всіх, провести слідчі експерименти.
Білий Колодязь, виклик, пошкодження трьох будинків. Треба поїхати.
Постійно іде потік матеріалу, який ми ледь встигаємо закінчувати, оформлювати.
Постійно ти береш додому, ти дописуєш щось там, дочитуєш, знаходиш щось, формуєш, ти завжди в цій рутині.
Приємного тут мало. Реально мало. Тут навкруги смерть і одні пошкодження.
Ось це ми тут їхали. Вони просто запускають дрони, бачать машину, їм без різниці. Їхали на службовій тоді.
І почали стріляти. Ось там було, два кілометри тому.
Шматок землі в машину, в бік - "бабах".
Коли дивилася фільми про війну до воєнного часу, то здається, що це дуже страшно і не уявляєш себе в такій обстановці.
Коли ти живеш в даній обстановці кожного дня, то ти вже не звертаєш на це уваги.
Можливо, організм зсередини якось на це і реагує, наприклад шию защемило, або ще якось.
Але мені здається, що я ніяк на це не реагую зовні.
Трішки смикнулася і все.
310 сантиметрів.
Думаю, міна...
Були в хаті, почули вибух сильний.
Двері в нас були відчинені в хату, я голову затулила і чую: скло посипалося. Ну де, ми не бачили - вибігли.
Перший вибух стався там десь, дим чорний пішов. На другий ми вскочили в підвал.
Тьотя Ніна викликала поліцію - сусідка, і ми викликали.
У мене руки трусяться, у мене істерика, я не знаю, що робити.
Це так усе неочікувано було, моментально. Я тільки наколотила чаю, думаю, поп'ю…
Крім городу тут нічого немає, ні техніки, ніяких військовослужбовців,
немає навіть критичної інфраструктури, яку полюбляють росіяни.
Можливо, вони хотіли поцілитися в кукурудзу, я не знаю…
Якщо це був приліт, ми збираємо матеріал, який можна буде застосувати в доказуванні в подальшому проти країни-агресора.
Це огляд місця події, фіксування за допомогою фотовідеоапаратури пошкодження будинків,
транспортних засобів, тілесних пошкоджень.
Ми збираємо усі довідки, допитуємо їх у якості потерпілих, у якості свідків.
Проживаю на вулиці Верхня, 77.
За національністю хто? - Українець.
Коли зайшли росіяни 24-го о 04:30, о восьмій ранку вони вже були під райвідділком.
Нас евакуювали до Старого Салтова, якраз де ми були на мосту. Там була стара база.
І начальник райвідділку розгубився, звісно, і поїхав. Дав команду і каже:
"Вирішуйте самі для себе: хто на Харків, хто назад на Вовчанськ, я поїхав".
Після окупації дуже багато людей знайомих повиїжджали за кордон.
Населення з 18 тисяч зараз 3-4 мігрує. І немає зовсім знайомих.
Залишилися лише люди похилого віку. Мало молодих. Тут людей зовсім нема, так би мовити.
24 лютого о 8 годині ранку військові РФ зайшли до відділку поліції нашого, окупували.
Як мені пізніше стало відомо, коли виїжджала з окупації, нам розповідали,
що тут селилися військові і тут були казарми.
Вони повністю зруйнували всі меблі, стіни пошкодили, вікна також, багато рам з вікон пошкоджені.
Взагалі цей райвідділ не дуже придатний для несення служби.
Бо взагалі треба нести службу 24/7, а тут немає опалення, світло пропадає, а також немає води.
У нас немає іншого вибору. Нам потрібно десь працювати. Працюйте тут - працюємо тут.
Бойові в нас далеко немаксимальні і несередні. Якось так.
І ми витрачаємо багато своїх коштів на ці переїзди, на ремонт своїх автівок,
на те, коли ми намагаємося ремонтувати гуму на колесах, оскільки вона постійно пробивається через осколки.
Я себе не вважаю героєм, тому що це професія, це не якесь досягнення - ми робимо свою роботу кожного дня.
Я вважаю, що керівництво країни-агресора, терористичної країни, навіть не країни, а утворення, яке схоже на країну,
буде притягнуте до відповідальності, обов'язково це відбудеться.
У це просто треба вірити і намагатися наблизити це якомога скоріше.
Як був трибунал у Нюрнберзі, так і ми повинні зробити свій Нюрнберг десь на території України.